welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz and this is another episode
of 15 minutes with a mentor series
which we're releasing in line with the
recruitment mentors community opening
and basically in this series we're going
to be talking to um some of the mentors
from inside the
community and uh asking them seven
questions
in 15 minutes so i'm delighted today to
be joined by arge
and but before we go into the question
and ask you the first one largely if you
introduce yourself for those that may
not know who you are and then
we'll get into it sure um so
my name is arjun gillard um everyone
calls me arge
um i head up the net division at
understanding recruitment
um i've been in recruitment for just
over nine years now
and started as a trainee with one
organization
worked my way up to head of engineering
and construction
managing over 20 people and then
moved out of that into tech recruitment
and went back into a billing manager
role
and have been basically spent the last
year and a half
uh growing.net and growing the team um
which has been very challenging through
the times for obvious reasons yeah of
course
nice well first question i have for you
in line with that so i want to know what
your biggest challenge was in 2020 and
how you overcame it and what you learned
from it
yeah um so the biggest challenge for me
probably was how to
manage and lead effectively remotely
um it was like i've never had
that experience before yes i've worked
from home a couple of days a week before
but my team more often than not were
always in the office
um and yeah it was just
sort of just a challenge getting used to
it um with things because
you don't get that sort of contact time
with everyone like we were catching up
two or three times a day with it and
for me i figured out pretty quickly
it doesn't and it shouldn't just be sort
of
work focused and like what have you done
today what have you achieved how did you
get on
um sort of it was more empathetic
with the team and sort of making sure
they're all right
um first and foremost because last year
in particular was
was challenging for um for everyone like
i was
i was living in the flat at that point
and
didn't really have any well have much
space so
my work-life balance was getting really
um affected by it because i was just
working all the hours under the sun
because i
had nothing else to do so um
yeah i i shared my almost shared my
problems with my team and said look i'm
struggling with this
what do you guys feel how do you feel
about it how are you coping with it and
it was like it was just a level playing
field with um
with the team um and it was like we're
we're in this together we'll get through
it together
um let's let's help each other um and
like i'm here to guide you and lead you
obviously but also you're here
to guide me and and lead me effectively
so
that worked out um that worked out
really well um
and i think the team team got a lot
stronger
for that really nice that's really
interesting thanks for sharing that so i
guess in line with that then
always interested about this so like
what working from home tip could you
share
with other recruiters listening to this
that has had a massive impact on your
own personal productivity would you say
um
actually work the hours that you should
be working
um and not not let it blur into one
thing so
i use my own laptop at home so what i've
done
now is i've got all my work-related
stuff
on google chrome and i've got all my
personal related stuff
on safari because i've got a macbook so
every time
every time i finish for the day i
sign out of teams i close chrome i sign
out of all my work stuff
and then i will go i'll go for a walk
and effectively have like a mini commute
home
as well and i do that first thing in the
morning too
so it actually feels like i'm going to
work and then
finishing work um as well that's
that's really helped me yeah great great
i love the
google chrome and foreign so
interesting to hear this so what's been
i know there's
different sort of ways but like for you
what's been the most effective way for
you to win business over the last 12
months
would you say um at the moment
it's been leveraging my network
um of people you know i've been in
recruitment for a long time as
i've said um it's not just tech
recruitment
now that i'm i'm leveraging all people
that i've met over the last year and a
half like
i've worked with some great people and
who have moved on and
gone into internal positions so i'm sort
of getting in contact with them
and just keeping in contact with them
but a lot of the stuff i've been doing
recently as well is being more active on
on social media and
actually creating content it's um
something that i've
been doing over the last couple of
months and really seen the benefit
um off it and it's not just oh i've got
a job
blah blah blah let me know if um if
you're interested
because it's like people don't care
people
like they don't want their feed um with
that the whole time like one of my
friends is a is a developer and he said
the amount of
recruiters he's actually disconnected
with because all he sees on his feed is
job job job like that so it's actually
posting things and giving back to the
community
and as well so i'm creating a net
insight report
um for this year so i've been running
like a survey over the last couple of
weeks so
i'm getting little bits of information
um
come through and i'm using that um to
create content
um as well which has been working really
well like i'm getting candidates come to
me
i'm getting sort of decision makers
saying oh i really like that
actually we're struggling with this can
we can we jump on a call and discuss it
um in more detail so yeah that that's
working for me
so yeah you haven't been just taking
you've you've been giving and then that
yeah it comes full circle i love that
yeah yeah exactly
what what habit or hobby did you start
in 2020 that you're going to continue in
2021
[Laughter]
um i started stretching oh my god i
always fell at that tell me about that
yeah um
well like i realized i'm really into the
gym and i realized that
i wasn't actually squatting properly i
wasn't dead lifting properly because
um i put a video up on instagram and my
mate who's a power lifter
um slated me for it and said that i was
doing it wrong so
that was fun and basically
he worked out that it was just like my
hamstrings and
various other bits my legs were were
really tight so
he said work on stretching work on
mobility and i was like i was always
someone where it's like nah
don't do stretching don't need to just
chuck a load of heavy weights about
um and that actually that actually
worked
really well for me and i started day by
day week by week started to see
sort of incremental improvements um and
i combined that
with sort of meditating using headspace
um as well which yeah sort of doing both
at the same time means that i'm actually
going to do it
in the morning and um it's then done so
yeah
i feel a lot more calmer now
is horrible um yeah i actually recently
bought a massage gun with the heart one
of them
yeah yeah oh my god yeah i spent half an
hour with it um
yesterday and um yeah my back was
my back was playing up i just laid on
the floor and my girlfriend just had it
it was just
sort of rubbing it along my back like
that very good yeah anyone that's
interested in stretching and these
things i would definitely recommend
looking at that
great investment um odds
what which do you think is better for
the first coffee in the morning
or the first pint post work on a friday
that's an interesting one um
i'd say i'd say the first point if it
was
if it was in a normal normal scenario
when you could obviously go to
the pub because yeah i'm very much
someone who
like i like to achieve and then get
rewarded for what i've done so like
the first point at the end of the friday
when it's been a hard week like if it's
been a great week happy days like it's a
celebratory point
if it's been a not so good week it's
almost like a commiseration and
um yeah you have a chat and a laugh with
your mates
about everything so um yeah i think that
first point nice fair enough
so next one is a bit more of a scenario
so i want you to share with us how you'd
approach this scenario so basically it's
a
particular business that's been on your
target client list for for over a year
for a while
and you've had a couple of touch points
with them different hiring managers over
that period so some
you may have spoke to a couple of them
um about
your um salary survey or they may have
engaged with some of your content you
might have sent them an email
and someone in your candidate network
managers to sort of pass on their
contact details and you call them
they pick up they answer they say hello
who is this and i want to know sort of
how you'd approach that and what you'd
say
cool um so yeah so
first of all i'd well just run with it
actually so hi
steve uh my name is arjun gillard i'm
from understanding recruitment
and i've previously spoken to sonya
who's your head of talent and david
who's the cto and we've had
various conversations about salary
survey that i sent out to them
and you actually liked one of my
linkedin posts
um a couple of weeks ago and so yeah
thanks very much for obviously engaging
in the content but
um the reason for my call um one of my
candidates who i've worked with and
placed
um called sharon um actually gave me
your phone number because
she said that i'd really be able to help
you and she actually worked with you in
your previous business
and so yeah i thought it was worth just
introducing myself and
seeing how i can how can i help well you
love that
nice first person to do like a little
role play respect
love that why not i absolutely love that
so last question is
with it being obviously for first
quarter of this year a lot of us would
have been thinking about our goals for
this year hoping for a better year
this year right so i wanted to sort of
think about what you'd want to share
with me or the recruiters listening so
if i'm a recruiter who set my goals for
2021 they're written down i'm feeling
extremely motivated
what would your advice be to me to sort
of give me the
that you think would give me the best
possible chance of actually achieving
the goals i've set myself cool so
i'd say the main thing when i do goal
setting is i
set myself achievable goals yes they've
got to be stretched but
if you're someone who's starting out in
a in a new market
and you like right i'm going to build i
want to build 400k this year or 500k
this year
is it actually going to be achievable
for you to do
if it's not i'd set something that is a
little bit more attainable
um another thing i do is set both
personal and professional goals
and i tie those in to each other and
then
make sure they're written down so i use
this thing called a zello journal
um which runs off a six month period
so you write your goals down at the
beginning of the
at the beginning of each week um you
sort of list what you're going to
achieve for that week and then it's got
a daily
um a daily target so then you can write
all that down and then
at the end of the week you tick off what
you've done
but you write what's good and what
you've achieved you write what
isn't as good and what you're going to
focus on for the week after
so like week by week it's just going to
be incremental and you're going to get
better and better and better
and then you're just constantly
reviewing those goals
as well and that's like i started using
that last year
and i noticed my productivity improved
so much even with working from home even
being on my own
um like yeah it was um it was really
helpful i love that so like anyone that
has set goals make sure that you've
broken those down
and yes yeah i love that i i've done
that some i personally have done it in
the last sort of six months and it's
it's the constant reviewing and having
visibility and what your goals are
rather than
writing them in january not looking at
them into i don't know maybe march or
later
yeah so um amazing arj thank you that
was
50 minutes of a mentor thank you thanks
thanks for having me